how about I'm a farruco and these are my
essentials
[Music]
my first essential is my wallet because
my wallet well because first
you have to go out with
money because you can't go out without money
that you can't buy anything this is my
identification also for  if something happens to me
my driver's license my credit card is the
same as what my mother did to me
who always where with the divine
child Jesus where protected and basically
this is number one the mask
I always have to wear my mask I like it
he understands me I feel more comfortable it
went unnoticed it's like the
mask we will never be able to get
used to it because I always stay on a
motorcycle or when I like to wear one
to travel too and for public places
tightening up is essential because they are
my  glasses I always have to wear
glasses I always
have around 100 pairs of glasses
easily I have my spot that I already know where they
sell the ones I like they understand what  and
like I like collectors and glasses
because I really like glasses that are
retro, he doesn't understand, for example, how are you wearing
versace that are from the 90s, the ones that
are dramas that I like,
another thing that can't be missing is this
watch that I always wear  with him this is the
most special because it was the first I am
crazy about this watch it is more than 1000
years old more than 15 years with me this watch and
obviously the grandmother's plate because
of the sentimental value it has already
passed away I have a photo that I have
communities  when I was little hugging her and I
really like special things that always
come with me they are like
good luck charms the goose as it can be missing
never understands
holland with was having dinner with with the
few laps of the we walk the cigarette in
case I have to learn a move she
understands me in  pandemic time do not pay
the mouth we are ready what else you can not
miss
a kitchen always enchants with
music with music for all the kitchen
or some bosses I can not be  ar without music
I go crazy totally necessary my life
I listen to everything I really like
Jamaican music reggae music
dance all I always spend listening to
another essential thing was this jacket on
my favorite it has the face of my grandfather it
has where I come from that  it's 167 the
name of my new album that's going to come out
also the name of the
main road where I live in bayamón and well
they made me with a lot of love and I
like it because it has racing flags
like racing ay I like
things from  cultivation
I like the flow
my phone is essential I always have
to carry it around it's a vice I don't know how to get
rid of it on the lookout for the internet
who doesn't walk around with their phone is always
part of using a lot of youtube
spotify apple percussion music
instagram
I'm fused with  a big list to
write my songs I'm also always
in the 'notes whatsapp is easier for me
always active
headphones are essential always from cinemas the
speaker  a are the usual ones I have to
be listening to music in my world they are
what I like so it is super essential
that most of the time I have one but it
is when he wants to listen to some range
the two to disconnect from the
world well obviously my medicine
I have two or  three conditions that I have
to treat once my feet have been
given and that was given as an
anti-inflammatory or muscle relaxant
I have problems with uric acid we
love it with a pill that I have
like him all the time, that is, they are
essential things  that already when
the years are falling on you well it has to
do with the medicine
cabinet thanks to my people so it's something to farrow these were min essential but
that they liked them and well that they
know a little more about how I manage
my life and things that  I have essentials in
my life farc